we've got angela in salt lake city hey
angela how's it going
good how are you good what's your
question today
so my husband and i are currently um
knocking out our debt
and most of our debt is coming from our
two vehicles
um and we both decided that we're going
to sell them the springs we've got
equity in them the problem that
i've got is my husband
wants to use some of that equity to
purchase a used dirt bike
for the summer um and i know
that it wouldn't have a loan on it um
technically we would still own
our vehicles outright because we'd be
down downgrading but
i just wanted to see what your input is
on that and if that's
a smart move or if it's a bad idea i
know that he's really
um his heart set on it and i've already
gotten him to agree with selling his
beloved truck
so i just kind of want to know
what what i can i can do yeah is your
husband there with you angela
no he's working anthony wants to show
directly to him angela could you give us
a call but i'm just kidding
she's sneaking it in while he's going i
know she's like oh he's gone oh let me
just get some outside input here i
love this and i know christie's gonna
have my workers
christie's gonna have my best i actually
have your back right now i'm still ready
for this
uh well hey listen so let me let me make
sure i understand this correctly
uh once you all sell your two cars
you're gonna be out of debt you will
have cash cards correct
yes okay cool how much money will you
have in your savings account well you
had a three to six
the three to six months in your savings
account
no we um have we currently have the 1000
in our emergency funds then yeah
i i hate to say this without your
husband being there because i want him
thinking we're talking behind his back
but you're right i mean
we shouldn't be purchasing anything
major like that we need to
lay down a solid foundation and to
prevent you all from going back into
debt you need a fully funded emergency
fund
so what you always combine household
income right now angela
uh about 95 000. okay so 95 000
what's your mortgage payment um
total with our hoa it's about sixteen
hundred dollars okay so sixteen hundred
dollars so right now
you need about ten grand in your savings
account to get the three to three months
of your expenses i would say
how much is the dirt bike i'm curious
so um initially he thought that he could
get one around three thousand but it
seems like the prices things are going
up and it's looking more like 4 500
yeah four to five hundred dollars so
four thousand five hundred dollars yeah
the kind of estimate he gave me
okay yeah yeah so that's half of your
your three to six months so
so no so no uh
you know what angela i gotta tell you i
when you said he has his heart set on it
like i i get that man i get my heart set
on things too the thing is
is we just have to be grown-ups and we
have to do things in the right order
and it doesn't mean he can't get the
dirt bite ever bike ever
it just means we're not going to get it
when we don't even have more than a
thousand dollars in our bank account
right does that make sense yeah that
makes sense yeah
so just just encourage him in that sense
when you break the news to him of this
news that anthony and i have given you
when he's been out of the house please
tell him it doesn't mean not
ever it just means not right now that's
our that's our advice for you
and here's a rule of thumb that i go by
uh christie for me
okay and this is not really something
that ramsay teaches it's just something
that i've been teaching
since i've come uh up underneath ramsey
and teaching something i don't really
buy something like that unless i can
afford it at least twice
okay so it's like for me when i purchase
my my used car
um if you follow me you know what i
purchased i won't say here on the radio
i didn't purchase it though until i had
at least
twice that amount in my account here's
why let's say he goes and buy the dirt
bike and he has the 5 000
cash and then he comes back home what
happens
he has no money he's broke so if an
emergency happens
no he doesn't have any money so for me
my philosophy is
on top of my emergency fund can i afford
to purchase this
twice if that's a gucci purse if that's
a
car if that's a backpack if that's
a kitchen remodel i remember you gave
that example a couple weeks ago when you
and i hosted together someone called in
with a
kitchen remodel and they had like the
exact amount of money and no cushion and
i remember you saying that same thing
yeah yeah you want you want to have some
cushion because you don't know
what will happen especially on the
kitchen remodel you remember that like
if the estimate is 20
000 oh you're going to spend about 25 to
30 000 on the car well and that
when that example with the kitchen yeah
you don't know how much something's
going to cost but even with the dirt
bike i mean
i hope nothing ever happens but that's a
very dangerous sport is it a sport yeah
it is
i don't know how the hobby whatever
that's that can be really dangerous and
i would hate for
anything to happen a record you have to
go to hospital anything like that with
something so risky
and you got a thousand dollars in your
pickup absolutely yeah yeah so i mean
that that's why i say
just make sure you can afford to buy it
twice i got that from jay-z for those of
y'all asking where i got it from